yo this is another video request some of
you guys asked me hey Daniel why do I
look better in the mirror then I look on
photos you're not alone it happens to a
lot of people so that's what we're going
to talk about in this video let's not
waste any more time let's get right into
it I have a dream made mistakes but
mistakes make you strong hey if this is
your first time here on my channel
welcome I'm Daniel instead of
subscribing and also clicking that
notification ballot so you won't miss
any of the next videos
so do it really look better in the
mirror than in photos yes and there's
four reasons for it so let's start with
the first reason
the mirror is a reflection so it's not
showing the real you it's showing us and
kind of reverse think about it you see
yourself every day in the mirror when
you brush your teeth when you're getting
ready for school or work or for whatever
so you get used to how you look like in
the mirror and over time you think that
that is normal but it's not because it's
not the real you so when you look at
yourself in a photo you see a flipped
version of yourself and immediately you
don't like it because of the opposite of
what you're used to so even though you
think you look better in the mirror
you're psychologically inclined to think
so because you're more used to it that's
not the only reason
[Music]
camera lens also plays a huge part
because you know they say that photo
never lies right but actually they do
because it can never show you the real
you not a hundred percent because of the
lens the angle and the light why do you
think so many people out there take so
many selfies from different angles
before ah they're finally happy but the
biggest problem is the lens and the
angle because of the distance and the
position between the camera and your
face the lens can distort certain
features of your face making them look
larger or even smaller than they really
are alright let's try those lens so now
it's far away right that's where you
wanted it you comes close that just
creates a lot of look it looks bad no
it's far away but I'm just gonna change
the angle of the camera look big
forehead and then you go in normal again
the other thing is the light right so
right now I'm in Japan we're standing in
front of the window
check it out hey Japan so the light is
right behind the phone right that's
where you want it if it's not if it's
the other way around look at my face
all right here it's cloudy and it's
still a little bit dark but still my
face look kinda okay right no look when
I changed the angle terrible terrible
now another and one of the biggest
reasons why we look so different in
photos than in the mirror is because
when we look at ourselves in the mirror
you move right you check yourself from
different angles and so you keep on
moving a picture is just a picture it's
2d it's not 3d we see ourselves in 3d so
it looks very different most experienced
models and notice and that is why they
look good in most photos by just
changing their pose a little
to get them better all right we are the
last one and the last reason is you yes
you why well you know when you're alone
and you're watching yourself in a mirror
you calm you're relaxed you're chilled
so when you smile it looks very natural
when you look seven ways and different
angles it looks natural but then when
you move with other people and they want
to take a photo and they say hey cheese
and you look and you see that camera
you're like oh no it's a camera I
already look bad in photos and then you
don't feel naturally more you don't feel
confident anymore and it shows in your
face and when they do that picture is
like yeah or you try to smile like you
know what I'm talking about you get that
that facial expression and the photos
don't look good because of you so what
can be done
are you just stuck will you just always
look bad in photos well no there's a few
tips and tricks and I made a whole
dedicated video for you that you can
check out right here now if you liked
the video give me a thumbs up subscribe
and I'll see you in the next video the
church
[Music]